so I see no fault in looking over the
not bad but just not as good at the so -
one of the greatest TV shows of all time
uh critic are you sure that's wise look
we're all adults and we're going to talk
about this in an adult wait so what's
the problem just that when people see
the word worst in the title they might
think the wrong thing well that's
technically what it is isn't it the
worst of the best
I'm not framed by a bunch of fanboys and
fangirls especially for a franchise I
love so much okay
shame your life had to end this way I'll
be fine thanks so without further ado do
you mind
I can hear you're all the way in here
that's an even bigger shame ja like I
was saying we're gonna look at the top
eleven yeah it is good episodes up an
all-around great series why top 11
because I like to go one step beyond so
sit back and enjoy the top 11
technically worst episodes of Avatar The
Last Airbender
sir I just received word from the Avatar
fanbase they say the nostalgia critic
has disgraced the franchise by doing a
top 11 worst episodes list how do you
wish to respond tell them I'll be
arriving in one week's time I look
forward to winning back the fanbase yes
sir nothing Moscow
let's not waste any time and take a look
at the top 11 best episodes why top 11
because I like to go one step beyond so
sit back and enjoy the top 11 Dante
Bosco you and Miss on the franchise and
so had dishonored me the time has come
to reclaim my honor you dishonorably
discharged with my honorably honoring my
honorable honor okay I have no idea what
you just said right now don't worry
you'll feel it quick what is it it's not
a fucking Bosco I think it's like the
campus juice or something honor
he thinks he's one of the characters
from Avatar don't trust me appropriate
attire maybe you can distract him right
look it's okay I'm doing a top 11 best
avatar episode you don't deserve the
chance okay look maybe we come to a
compromise I can give you a really
glowing review and take the lead
Oh
Oh hot it's time to fight fire with fire
and soap that knows how to do it ah and
us lost boys have to stick together
Tamra that's not avatar
that's hook what are you talking like a
pirate why the Pirates talk about
pirates oh now you need to try harder I
want you to go home do some research
keep me updated on your progress okay
okay all right buddy it's time to show
you who's boss well we'll show you who's
boss right
crack credit sorry Malcolm Evan needs of
me outweigh the needs of you he's gonna
kill me well that's show business for
you just try to keep him entertained
while I start the countdown thank you
Ray
while they're wildly gaining out there
why don't we go ahead start the top 11
best avatar episode critic it's okay I
took care of Bosco oh hey great I knew
you could take him yourself
but wait where's Malcolm damn and
Malcolm McKinley you broke under
pressure sorry I was wait you just can't
get good help great sauce
so I could bag me some more ladies in my
cab whoa bitches
you
that's got something connected to
firebending around here ah here we go
all right Dante I think you've met your
match no no no Tamara it's the wrong
costume again no but I'm a ninja no no
it doesn't matter we have a theme going
and we need to stick to the theme
understand I kind of like it hey this
doesn't concern you now look I want you
to go home do some research and call me
when you finally wiki something okay
fine
it's a good try thank you hey don't
encourage him
- man you stupid stupid man give it fast
so that's what I have known my mom
alright I'm get the multitask here a
little bound got to learn how to
firebend while also continuing the
countdown so with that said lesson one
number seven
aha I think I got it what an engaging
read all right you Filipino Benjamin
Button face the power my fire Fezzik you
know I loved you in Slumdog Millionaire
wait no that wasn't you
I'm sorry I always confuse you with oh
oh oh you're fourth wall jokes won't
save you I'll put these comments doesn't
good use I'm out of ammo
just wieners overrated
wait no good you're gonna hit the
commercials have button
okay number fucking four-stroke bucket
and the number one greatest Avatar
episode it prepare to meet the great Mel
Lord in the sky oh how the hell can my
body take so much abuse women Dante I
only have one episode left before it is
avatar episode of all time would it be
more honourable if both you and I talked
about light so wonderful but then you
wouldn't be punished the only one you're
punishing is yourself man I mean look at
you
look like The Karate Kid with pinkeye
you're trying so hard to show up the
best of Zuko for the fans when really we
should be thankful there either was a
zoo go to begin with you don't need to
do that you're already fucking beautiful
Ghazi let's go you're awesome you don't
need to put on this show for us
so what do you say Dante stop with the
Zuko and get with the yo-yo you had me
into that last line yeah I really
fucking kill it the rest is pretty good
though
thank you so what do you say man can we
do this why the hell not
the number-one avatar episode is bare
now wasn't that fun to do Dante Dante
yep I admit I was spending too much time
focusing on being Zuko instead of
focusing on what's really important fair
now you see isn't that so much better
just to be yourself I guess or uh ha the
american dragon jake long what up what's
the dealio don't be all mean being coy I
got it I finally got the right cost
oh fuck you Dante Bosco